la situation à kiev à présent les russes
se sont retirés de la région depuis plus
d'un mois maintenant à mesure que les
jours passent les ukrainiens découvre un
champ de ruines on retrouve ar pin notre
envoyé spécial bastien renouil
cette résidence dire pin la banlieue qui
avait été touché par plusieurs tirs
d'obus qui ont tout détruit ici et qui
ont mis le feu aux appartements qui
n'ont pas été directement endommagé que
le voir derrière moi il n'y a plus rien
dans cette pièce difficile d'ailleurs de
savoir de quoi il s'agit probablement
une chambre étant donné qu'il y à se
mettre là sur le sol qui a complètement
brûlé et cette télévision en face qui a
totalement fondu venu je vous amène dans
d'autres pièces
il y avait environ 400 habitants dans
cette résidence est plus personne
aujourd'hui elle a été complètement
évacué il est bien trop dangereux d'y
résider tout pourrait s'effondrer alors
il ya des volontaires qui viennent ici
pour enlever les derniers meubles qui
reste qu'ils n'ont pas été détruits pour
les entreposer ailleurs le temps que ces
bâtiments soient détruites par des
bulldozers et que de nouvelles
habitations soient construites
mais les russes qui ont détruit sept
résidences n'ont pas fait que la
détruire ils ont aussi résider pour
preuve ces rations de l'armée russe qui
sont encore en cuisine ici du sucre la
de la confiture les russes qui pendant
la présence sur place ont tué de très
nombreux civils selon la police
ukrainienne plus de mille deux cent
corps ont été retrouvés depuis la fin de
l'occupation et parmi eux 200 n'ont pas
pu encore être identifiées